Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure is a
classic film that the whole family can
enjoy of course there are plenty of
jokes and concepts that fly over the
heads of younger viewers from historical
implications to weird family dynamics
these are the things only adults notice
in Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure over
the course of this awesome film Bill and
Ted meet and befriend a number of major
historical figures and bring them back
to participate in their history report
at San Dimas high school since the film
is a comedy it doesn't spend a lot of
time digging into the implications of
this but any adults who has even studied
a little bit of history knows that there
are many worth unpacking and some of
them are pretty heavy for example Bill
and Ted bring back several icons who
died suddenly and violently Abraham
Lincoln was assassinated in the spring
of 1865 Socrates was executed by forced
poisoning in 399 BC and Joan of Arc was
burned at the stake in 1431 before she
reached her 20th birthday again Bill &
Ted's Excellent Adventure is a comedy
and it's also a movie that's meant to
portray history as a fun journey full of
interesting stories so it makes sense
that the film doesn't dig too deep into
what happens to these doomed individuals
after they leave San Dimas
although the adults in the room know
that Joan's plan to institute an
aerobics program for French soldiers
probably isn't going to work out bill
and Ted spend a lot of their excellent
adventure traveling through thousands of
years of history making a few key stops
along the way and bringing historical
figures back to their hometown what the
film doesn't tell us though is exactly
what impact if any their travels had on
various civilizations after the
adventure was over we know that Rufus
Bill and Ted's time-traveling helper
eventually brought the English
princesses from the past to the present
but other than that it's all left up to
the imagination still some of the
history makers have bigger plans than
others of all these people
Napoleon is the one who spends the most
time in the modern era he hangs out for
almost a full day in San Dimas and
spends a lot of time at the local water
park Waterloo where he has a blast by
the time of the big history report
Napoleon has become so infatuated with
waterslides that he's planning a new
strategy for invading Russia based on
them as he reveals with a map and toy
soldiers when Ted says he doesn't think
the strategy will work
liyan immediately becomes angry the film
ends before we can learn if Napoleon
stuck to his guns and his water slides
so did Bill and Ted improve Napoleon's
military mind by bringing him to the
present or did they destroy it did he
lose his empire more quickly or did he
learn important strategic lessons about
defending his territory though most of
the film focuses on Bill and Ted as they
travel through time it does include some
peeks into their home lives we learned
that Bill has a stepmother named Missy
who's so young that she was a senior in
high school when he was a freshman
though the film doesn't spend a lot of
time on Missy's place in the story it
does not in the direction of a few
things that make bill's relationship
with Missy Wells complicated hi Bill
what a ride
sure Missy I mean long since she's
married to his dad bill would rather
forget that Missy used to just be a girl
he knew in high school however he can't
help but see her as more of a
contemporary than a parent then of
course there's Missy's apparent
attraction to older academic men we see
it in Bill's father but we also notice
it in response to Bill and Ted's history
teacher mr. Ryan who Missy seems very
happy to bump into at the end of the
film these are all just brief moments
but they certainly paint a picture of an
unconventional stepson stepmother
relationship that most young viewers
wouldn't catch still it might be
something that bill should talk to
someone about yeah just got a minor
oedipal complex when Rufus explains how
the time machine works he's careful to
point out that no matter where in time
they go they're still facing a ticking
clock time will continue to flow
normally for them we're reminded of this
when Ted tells his past self that he
should remember to wind his watch so
they don't forget how much time they
have left this detail is useful because
it puts restrictions on Bill and Ted's
travel and gives the story higher stakes
it also raises another question since
Bill and Ted are moving in real time as
they journey through history should we
assume that valuable days are also
passing in the original timelines of
their historical friends this opens up
all kinds of possible outcomes
what if Lincoln missed the Gettysburg
Address because he was hanging out at
maul oh yes on the other hand what if
Joan of Arc was never captured and
burned at the stake because she was busy
helping Bill and Ted with their history
assignment at its core this film is a
journey of friendship as the two title
characters travel through time not only
do they learn some basic facts about the
past they also learn how to appreciate
history as a world of exciting and
nuanced stories most of the film is
devoted to that journey but Bill and Ted
aren't the only ones taking a big
life-changing trip each of the
historical figures who travel with Bill
and Ted beginning with Billy the Kid and
Socrates go on their own journey in
which they also learn and grow we first
see this in a small way when Billy the
Kid picks up some of Bill and Ted slang
not bad it's so great where are we dude
however that's far from the end of
everyone's learning experiences
rewatching this film as an adult we
can't help but imagine what types of
ideas these travelers brought back to
their own times
Beethoven was introduced to 20th century
rhythms and synthesizer sounds that
could have influenced his remaining
compositions Freud witnessed a number of
modern behaviors that might have
informed his theories on psychoanalysis
and Genghis Khan discovered several new
tricks when it comes to weaponry and
warfare we know we're just
philosophizing here but above everything
else it would be awesome if everyone
could have learned and spread the film's
to central themes to be excellent to
each other and of course check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about classic
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you
[Music]